hi there Here I am I'm about to head off
to the airport after a wonderful stay
here in montreal montreal is a great
city it's not the most beautiful city in
the world but a great place for a
language festival you hear so many
languages in the street I'm sure there's
no one here only speaks one language
many speak English and French and you
hear lots of other languages
another advantage here in Montreal is
this fabulous bookstore it is the best
language learning bookstore I have ever
seen and one of the people at LAN fest I
mean he learned so much from other
people there told me about it and I went
in and I spent about $200 I'll admit but
I got 10 books for $200 some are more
expensive some are less expensive
excellent books in the university
bookstores as I said in my last video
like at at the bookstore in the in
Stanford in the United States it was
like 150 200 dollars for one lousy book
[Music]
okay
so anyway I have four videos that I did
with Doc one with dr. crashing one with
who did we do now that Mark Pendleton of
coffee break languages will Richard
Simchat and Lydia so we will put those
up for you and you can learn from them
of course I've every day I discover new
things on Linc and this morning I
discovered that a great way to work on
my Hebrew writing which is my first
challenge I got to get better at reading
the language so that I can
let the truck go by by doing the
dictation function I go into my
vocabulary section and I turn the
settings on my flash cards on my
activities to a dictation and so I'm
actually having to do dictation and
write in Hebrew I have my iPad on the
Hebrew keypad and of course if you make
a mistake in front of a teacher or in a
classroom it's annoying and stressful
but if you're working by yourself and
you get every single word wrong it's not
a big problem and you gradually get
better at noticing and I I stress again
the importance of of noticing and
language learning and doing activities
that enable us to notice better we can't
possibly review all the words I can't
forever be doing dictation but these are
activities that increase our alertness
and make us better at noticing things so
we'll let this group walk by and my on
my plane back to Vancouver and we'll
continue taking on Greek and Hebrew bye
for now
[Music]